alright guys so we're gonna be playing a
little bit of gigantic today my name is
justin i'm joined by eric esport stay
and while developers here with us
they're going to be playing gigantic
it's just so it's still in closed beta
it's not open to everybody but the india
in da has lifted so we're able to start
talking about it able to start showing
it off and they really want to get the
word out about you know what people
think about it it's been closed off for
so long and you play through a little
bit of it it to start off haven't eaten
yeah I played a little bit not as much
as hopefully some of the guys that we're
on the skype call with yeah but I will
be trivial um yes but I played at least
three kayli words minimum of three good
job I'm here in a second I think I might
have those I can no longer hear
ourselves good which is not a good sign
but hold on guys which might mean to
check I hear you guys but I guess that's
skype hear you
at least we're not lonely this is going
swimmingly so it's a good way to start
off fine yeah making sure things don't
work I guess so because I yeah that's
kind of the early beta thing you just
make sure the people who are really
interested stick around too many buttons
here this is it's like being in a space
shuttle I don't know what's happening
don't don't ask me um yeah I turned it
down ready I can hear us know how about
now can you hear us now yes yeah I can
hear us okay finally I guess I guess we
just had to turn it up all right here
you know what we'll just do this again
cuz it's the internet right we can
totally do this we're just gonna do this
again none of that it's like our do-over
yeah exactly thick see even the dev snow
see alright Justin paunchy let's try
this again please late never even
happened I don't know we're talking
about exactly hey guys i'm justin here
joined by eric esport stay and we're
gonna be playing a little bit of
gigantic now gigantic isn't a brand new
game of course it's been out there for a
little bit in alpha and beta stages but
the NDA has finally lifted on the beta
that we have out there doesn't mean it's
open to everybody although after this
we're gonna be sitting out some code so
I'll be able to try it out into play for
yourself uh but we're gonna be playing a
little bit with a with Eric over here
who knows the game very well and because
we are not actually eSports we brought
some developers with us Joe pick up and
James Finney if you guys could introduce
yourselves really quick sure yeah hey
man I'm I'm Joe pick up i'm a the
character lead on the game yeah James
Finney head up the dev team cool and
help so today is the first day that it's
kind of come out of India you guys have
been working on it for a while then it's
been in a closed beta for quite a bit
yeah so it's a you know really exciting
to get to the point where you feel like
we can let people you know stream talk
about it tell everybody about the
experiences are having good and back
hopefully mostly good in a nutshell uh I
think we you know we know what jogging
it is but in a nutshell if you were just
going to condense it down what is
gigantic uh you know it looks like a
shooter it looks like maybe a mix like
if you hear about heroes you might think
it's a MOBA if you just now get it you
might think that it's just an overwatch
or team fortress 2 type shooter but what
is this game so it's a really fast paced
team-based competitive game you know
it's a has really strong roots in action
gaming definitely strong shooter
influence and and takes a few things
from MOBAs as well so you know we what
we like to think of you know when we
talked about starting this project was
wanted to make something that people be
not having any trouble kind of relating
to just jumping in and like find it easy
to control the characters and get in and
enjoy the action but make something that
was entirely unique you know you're not
going to make a classic by just copying
what's out there so we think gigantic
something new and we'll get a chance
hopefully to see a little bit of of that
newness in action so what what is it
that we're able to experience now what
is the closed beta encompassing yeah so
close beta has a sorry chatter going on
behind me I about 16 heroes in it and to
Guardian so one of the things is unique
about the game is you're playing five on
five BVB and you know you're on a team
and you have heroes that you pick out
the beginning to your lock in for the
whole match playing that that hero and
then as you go you upgrade but one of
the really different things about the
experience is there's a sixth member of
your team which is this gigantic
creature called a guardian your goals to
kill the enemy teams guardian they're
trying to kill yours and so gigantic
right now has two Guardians layron who's
this giant bulldog of a Griffin using
kinda holy magic and you know shooting
beams out of her eyes and then gren
who's this giant dragon anagha creature
that's uh poisoning you send you on fire
and represents a little bit different
feel who well I don't think there's a
better way to describe the game then
actually watching it since we're in
video we might as well jump into a match
I think we're all teamed up already and
good to go oh we actually I rien vited
you I joined you I believe I'm in the
group just a preface Justin says I'm
amazing I'm I'm okay at this game uh
there's I'm basically the backpack today
for the devs there
gonna be carrying me their backs
probably gonna hurt quite a bit but I
have faith in them and minor faith in my
own ability to not screw things up so
you know on that note you know yeah
we're gonna we're gonna see how this
goes ya know me to pop with you let's do
it all right oh I gotta get that fortune
card draw so whoa you know we haven't
played together and one of the things we
try to do with gigantic is uh make it so
that people with different gaming
backgrounds different kind of play style
choices can get in and and have a good
time and so a lot of different
characters are designed for people who
like different kind of game so depending
on whether you're more of a shooter guy
or a more action game or whether you
want something a little more cerebral
that's still super fast paced that might
you know determine what kind of
character you want to play so what kind
of character yu tendo play as in these
games take um for this I I started
playing back in a little bit and I
enjoyed it it's kind of like that
shooter elements to it so it kind of
resonates especially since that's kind
of just what I've been playing more
recently so having a crosshair there and
aiming with that and just having you
know duel like kind of like submachine
gun pistol and a cannon and a grenade
you know that all feels pretty shooter
II right there you know yeah Beckett
definitely you know our thought was we
wanted you know she's actually meant to
be the character if you come from a
shooter background that's like the
easiest introduction to the game it's a
game that seems to borrow from both a
lot of different art styles and a lot of
different backgrounds it where did you
guys come up with a story for this or is
there an overarching more around the
game uh yeah there is there's there's um
so you know we're just gonna see a
little bit of it here because it's beta
and because the game is you know very
pvp focused but uh we'll be fighting
either on the side of a house Orien with
their you know Griffin or on the side of
house daveigh dro with their noggin so
both both sides are trying to take
control over over the area sort of bind
their Guardian to it and so we're will
be taking on the roles of heroes that
are escorting that Guardian and helping
it take over the territory why do you
want to take over the territory is there
some overarching reason other than you
know we
we're badasses who just take over things
and okay yeah I it's sort of a struggle
for power within the Empire and then in
the long run what we hope to do is let
players form their own houses and join
into that that that power struggle the
one thing that's really interesting
about this game is that it does fully
support cross-play so over here at the
game but offices we're playing on xbox
ones but you guys are on pc right yeah I
what led to the decision to allow that
cross-platform play I mean it's
something that we asked for in so many
games but so if you actually deliver it
for us you know it's a question mark for
us for a while I mean for one you know
we started out developing the game on pc
but it was it was clear from an early
state that that this was a game because
of the kind of action oriented nature uh
and simplicity of controls could work
both on PC and on console and so what we
wanted us to you know we we even before
we knew we were doing a console version
our lead gameplay engineer had set up
controller support just because he'd
been working on some console shooters
recently and he thought that would be
pretty fun and when we started talking
to Microsoft about the possibility of
bringing xbox when they're like that
would be great but you know we've got
this thing in the works yet that's not
announced where we're really trying to
just break down all the barriers for
gamers between playing on windows and
playing on xbox one and you know day and
we both thought that gigantic with
perfect game to take advantage of that
and I think free-to-play also used to be
something that was a very negative word
which I think people are slowly changing
their mind about because you can offer
really good experiences then that are
free but aren't necessarily the
free-to-play that we used to think of it
sag antic is a free-to-play experience
right yeah yeah it's totally true I
think we're we're just starting to talk
about how a lot of that stuff works but
you know obviously you know you don't
want the game to feel like it's a